Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my loki episode 1 video we are burdened with
glorious episodes finally so i'm doing videos
for all the episodes in season one be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're doing a giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know what your
favorite easter egg from the episode was careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet
we'll be talking about everything and i'll just
start at the beginning of the episode and number
these as we go along and talk about easter eggs
and moments they set up a lot of really big stuff
but it is the first episode so there's a lot of
table setting and explaining what's going on
but starting at the beginning the title of the
episode is glorious purpose a reference to his
catchphrase from the first avengers movie which
he repeats during the episode he repeats a lot of
his dialogue in his big speeches from the avengers
movies but it's also a reference to loki finding
a new glorious purpose at the end of the episode a
new mission given to him by mobius new opportunity
i can't give you salvation but maybe i can give
you something better owen wilson was fantastic
during the episode as mobius i'll explain his
character in a second too but he also calls
loki on a lot of his bull crap like what is your
glorious purpose what would happen if you became
king of midgard king of earth would you become
king of space next what would you do if you're a
king of space and it's like loki doesn't have an
answer for that like he's not thought it through
that much but the episode starts in the same
avengers and game time travel scene to 2012 with
them redoing the elevator scene of them carting
loki off they did change this a little bit they
added some footage and they got rid of some stuff
just kind of speed things along like they zoom
in on his face as he's waving goodbye to the hulk
as they make him take the stairs but they speed
run to the part where loki gets his hands on the
tesseract so they can just get to the moment where
he portals away and winds up in the gobi desert
it is a very iron man one inspired scene they have
that funny moment with the locals where he sort of
rushes to sort of collect himself and stand on
the rock like he's getting ready to perform for
them and he gives him the same loki i am burdened
with glorious purpose speech that he gave at the
beginning of the first avengers movie they also
give him his own custom version of the marvel
intro logo just like they did on wandavision and
falcon and winter soldier it wasn't quite as crazy
on falcon and winter soldiers was on one division
the loki version just changes the logo to loki
green but just as the locals are giving him the
business like what are you who are you what are
you doing here the time variance authority hunters
and the minutemen portal in so that's what they're
calling these hunters here they're calling them
the minutemen most of the naming scheme of the tva
is based on puns for time travel then hunter b15
wumi mosaku's character comes in she's sort of one
of the main characters in the series even though
all these characters are part of the tva she's
like one of the main hunters i made the night
court reference in a previous video she's kind of
like raw's from night court the bailiff who will
just wreck you if you look at them the wrong way
because the tva is kind of like night court for
mcu time travel villains she starts talking about
the rate of change in the timeline the slope the
increase so during the episode when they talk
about branch timelines hitting redline what that
means is that it approaches a certain limit when
it eventually becomes a fully alternate reality so
they want to stop it from hitting redline and clip
the branch so to speak which is what those special
devices are that they use here so it basically
resets this part of the timeline this localized
area as if it never happened for these people
but you also get a good sense for some of their
other core technology too like they have those
stun batons but they also have what they call the
time twisters which basically alter the flow of
time for individual people so loki just winds
up there feeling the sting as if it's like a
continuous punch that just goes on for a minute
it's actually a little bit sinister you can use
that to torture someone something fierce and there
are a lot of sinister overtones with the whole
idea of the tva and the timekeepers that i'll talk
about as we go through the rest of the episode
very clearly foreshadowing them is some of
the bigger antagonists in the series there are
obviously some big twists that they foreshadowed
during the episode too like the people you think
are the villains probably aren't the real villains
when he says he's had a very long day he's
referring to his failed invasion of earth during
the first avengers movie with thanos shitauri
forces and says that he's had his fill of idiots
and armored suits referencing the avengers then
she muzzles him with that control collar which
is very similar to the control collar that thor
put on him preventing him from using his powers
and binding him to that special time twister
then they set the reset device and take loki back
to the time keeper's citadel at the end of time
the technical term for it in the comics is the
citadel at the end of time because it was created
literally at the end of the timeline before the
heat death of this version of the universe but
within the mcu the way they talk about this place
this whole facility it sort of exists in its own
little pocket dimension outside the normal flow
of space-time so it's protected from things like
thanos snapping the infinity gauntlet so none of
these people in this place got snapped by thanos
but you can see how some of these other moments
early on are meant to answer some of the biggest
questions like how come we've never heard about
you till now loki even asked that question to
mobius he says well because you've never had to
which is kind of a meta answer too to the audience
was because we never really needed to tell a time
travel story until after avengers end game in
this big multiverse overarching story of marvel
phase 4 that we're in the middle of right now
but within the context of the story the reason why
nobody really talks about the tva in the avengers
movies because they don't know about them is
because they've been using the time reset devices
every time something has happened implying that
there have been times when things have happened
but i love their design language for the tv8 it's
got this very tactile 1970s sci-fi vibe to it very
british seeming too like they're mixing a lot
of classic sci-fi series like the hitchhiker's
guide meets doctor who meets the citadel of rix
from rick and morty and if you are a big rick and
morty fan the show runner michael waldron actually
came from rick and morty season 3 to do this show
and he also wrote doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness the loki series is their first
legit multiverse series in the marvel cinematic
universe so it will have some crossover elements
that help set up doctor strange 2 the same way
that wandavision did and i will talk about the
whole multiversal war that they reference which
is obviously a big secret wars lead up they
tease a ton of stuff there is a lot of setup for
many many different things so don't be surprised
if you re-watch the episode a couple times and
you keep finding new things and new easter eggs
but the whole idea of the citadel of ricks on
rick and morty is funny because it was actually
based on marvel's council of reeds in the comics
they're a multiverse team of reed richards from
alternate universes who team up to create a think
tank so loki doing rick and morty is kind of like
them completing the circle of references a marvel
project referencing something else that itself
was referencing marvel but as she takes loki into
book him we see a variant scroll being booked
then just another human douchebag red shirt that
they're using for comedy during the episode as
part of loki's journey who claims his father
is super rich and on the board of goldman sachs
they also use this scene to demonstrate how the
other time travel tech works preventing loki the
other prisoners from escaping like i said just
kind of meant to set up some of the jokes at
the end of the episode when he starts using the
technology against them they also use this to set
up the joke with a desk clerk about the infinity
stones and the tesseract later in the episode
with his desk drawer full of all kinds of versions
of infinity stones from different universes like
infinity stone that sounds stupid that's marvel
basically making fun of themselves too for using
the infinity stones as such big plot devices for
the entire 10-year run of the infinity saga movies
bit of a meta reference for marvel phase 42
kind of like saying that infinity stones will
not be a thing during marvel phase 4. then she
introduces loki to the processing queue he goes
on about how amazing his fine asgardian leather
costume is didn't know he was such a closed horse
it vaporizes it right off his body you get that
funny scene with him being naked then they have
this very funny complicated system of floor drops
where they drop him a couple levels through each
different room sticking him automatically in a
prison jumpsuit as he has to verify every single
word that he's ever uttered you have that funny
scene with a cat which is probably not a cat as
a lot of you have probably guessed a cat is never
just a cat in the mcu now it's probably a florkin
then they promptly dump him down another level
and make him verify that he was born as an organic
being and he does have a soul they use it for a
couple of jokes too like loki wonders for a second
like wait a minute what if i were a robot and i
didn't know it like for just a hot second he does
kind of wonder wait a minute am i really a person
but what they're referencing there though are
beings like vision and ultron living machines that
technically don't have souls although if you are
a big star trek the next generation fan there was
a very notable episode that dealt with this exact
idea the whole idea that data did not have a soul
and by the end the court decided that it was up to
data to decide for himself whether or not he had
a soul they take that photograph of his temporal
aura sort of to set up some of the later twists
in the episode they sort of use those to track
the different variants so like you leave your
aura your temporal aura on things that you touch
when you travel around the multiverse it's like a
more complex version of a time travel fingerprint
as they travel into the queue you see a bunch of
posters we see miss minutes if her voice sounded
familiar that's because tara strong is the voice
of miss minutes most of the posters all the flair
all over the building in the different parts of
the episode are all references to time travel like
this one reads behave don't get your clock cleaned
and when they say clean they mean scrubbed as in
deleted which we see happen within a couple
minutes of this they also play a lot of time
travel jokes too like miss minutes repeats the
exact thing that loki said as if they knew that
he was going to say it but then as he's going
through the queue this minutes basically gives
him the tutorial on the tva the history of the tva
and it says the tva was created because of a vast
multiversal war that's a reference to marvel's
secret wars happening in the future of the mcu
i'll probably do a separate video about
this because we've all been talking about
secret wars even the russo brothers have been
talking about doing a version of secret wars
in the avengers movies with all these alternate
timelines fully alternate realities battling each
other for supremacy like a bunch of variant
universes battling each other until the time
keepers emerged and created what they call the
single sacred timeline for the entire multiverse
so the way they're canonizing time travel in
the mcu timelines is that there's one timeline
that encompasses the entire multiverse all these
alternate universes and when a new branch timeline
is created they treat it like a fully alternate
reality and those happen through nexus points
big major events that alter the flow of time
but during this part of the episode and then
later several times in the episode loki has this
big speech there are other big speeches about the
nature of free will people not really having free
will because the time keepers dictate everything
that's supposed to happen everyone's destinies
it's meant to give off a very sinister vibe
because when mobius is calling loki out for his
avengers speech giving to all those people from
the first avengers movie about them craving to
be subjugated free will being a bad thing it's
the same idea with the time keepers in the tva
so i feel like that's a big foreshadowing moment
that the time keepers themselves are going to
wind up being bigger antagonists in the series
than this other alternate loki that they're trying
to hunt down you also notice during some of these
animations like when he's describing variants
you notice the background looks exactly like the
landscape on titan from avengers infinity war but
a lot of you will probably remember one division
when they mentioned nexus event because nexus
was a big concept they introduced on one division
that was meant to be an easter egg for scarlet
witch as a nexus being in the mcu so nexus
beings are rare individual entities with the
ability to affect probability in thus the future
thereby altering the flow of the universal time
stream or the sacred timeline as they call it on
the loki series these beings each referred to as
a nexus like scarlet witch act as the keystones of
the multiverse and are crucial to its ultimate
coherence in stability so these beings nexus
beings are vigilantly watched over by the cosmic
forces like the time variance authority in the
time keepers to be aware of any temporal changes
so for instance loki is not a nexus being but
because he had the infinity stone he was able to
create a big enough change that it created these
branch timelines what they're saying is that
scarlet witch as a nexus being doesn't need an
infinity stone to do that she could change the
future on this scale without that that'll sort of
play into the idea of doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness listen to your connection point to
that movie from the loki series but they also
give you the tva's official slogan for all time
always as written by what they're calling the
narrative commission the funny meta reference
here the narrative being a reference to the story
of the mcu like for instance kevin feige is the
head of the narrative commission of marvel studios
because he says what the story is going to be
but then them melting this douchebag is just
meant to be a call back to thor ragnarok and that
funny moment where thor freaked out watching the
grandmaster melt his underling after he himself
going through a similar type of processing queue
then they play the loki title screen and obviously
the shifting style of the letters of his name
are meant to be references to all the alternate
versions of loki that we'll see during the series
then we get into the storyline with this alternate
loki that's going around killing tva hunters
in 1549 france mobius investigating the scene
of one of these crimes so my early theory here
just based on all the evidence they've provided
and all the trailer footage that we've seen is
probably lady loki the female version of loki
that they're hunting down but the way they explain
it this other loki had apparently set a trap for
the tva they sort of pay this off at the end of
the episode too like purposefully setting a trap
for them so that she could steal this special time
reset device i believe this stained glass window
behind mobius as he's talking about the crime
here is meant to be joan of arc because we're
in france in a church and it's meant to foreshadow
the lady loki twist being responsible for all this
like they're using joan of arc's story as a
metaphor for the story of lady loki if you're
not a big history buff joan of arc was burned at
the stake for heresy against the church the tva is
kind of like a timed church so to speak they call
it the sacred timeline they erase people burn them
kind of so to speak it kind of looks like they're
being burned or vaporized here when they're deemed
variants or heretics against the main timeline so
it's like lady loki on the loki series is joan of
arc metaphorically which also plays into the idea
that she is not the real villain here even though
they're kind of portraying her that way at the
beginning of the series like i said a lot of big
twists that they're setting up here the showrunner
also clarified the stained glass window depiction
of the devil here and the director also backed
this up that at no point did they ever discuss
mephisto on the series so this depiction of the
devil is not meant to be mephisto although they
do make a nightmare reference later in the episode
too nightmare and mephisto completely different
characters we find out that this alternate loki
possibly lady loki gave this little kid in the
church the kablooey gum the devil bearing gifts
reference blueberry but then just as they're
about to reset this part of the timeline another
agent steps through and hands him the file on
this version of loki notice all the stuff on his
file here too it also correctly identifies his
race as a frost giant even though he was born
a runt his birthplace is yodenheim home of the
frost giants and notice the sector reads up to
2099 that's a reference to marvel's 2099 comic
book story universe like spider-man 2099 who was
played by oscar isaac during spider-man into the
spider-verse in big coincidence oscar isaac is
also playing the live-action version of moon
knight in the moon knight disney plus series the
whole thing with loki's gender being fluid is just
a reference to lady loki like i said all this
pointing to lady loki easter eggs but then we
meet gugu M'Batha-Raw's judge Renslayer character
she's based on ravvona renslayer from the comics
long time love interest of king the conquer she
said that the loki series is meant to be something
of an origin story for her as well so she
expects to come back in other marvel projects if
we see more kang the conquer easter eggs from her
storyline i'll point them out for the most part i
believe that she's supposed to be a good character
there's a lot of foreshadowing with her character
in this big tva time keepers reveal as well but
the three faces above her aren't so much meant to
be a reference to king the conqueror as they are
meant to be the faces of the three time keepers
from the comics but the middle face above her does
look similar to one of kang's faces she identifies
this loki variant as number l1130 charged with
sequence violation 720 89. i feel like the date
is probably somebody's birthday but i don't know
whose we get that funny speech from loki trying to
talk his way out of the situation trying to throw
the avengers under the bus oh well the only reason
i'm here that i have the tesseract is because
they time traveled in the first place believe me i
would know the stench of two tony stark's cologne
which itself is another reference to the axe body
spray joke from avengers end game like what are
you wearing there is that axe body spray then they
sort of answer the question of why the avengers
weren't hauled in because the avengers according
to the timekeepers wishes did what they were
supposed to do they were supposed to time travel
then as loki sort of takes her to task on all
this like how do you know that this is the time
keeper's will like what are you doing here the way
she talks about it ravana she's never actually met
the time keeper so i think it's going to be one of
those revelations where it's like have you met the
timekeepers have you met the timekeepers no have
you no i haven't met them either how does anyone
know that this is really what their will is to
make a wizard of oz reference who is behind the
curtain but then they set him up for that big
joke of him trying to use his powers to escape
but the control collar prevents him from using
them they also explain that there's a wide area
nullifier that just covers the entire area of
the tva's time citadel that prevents people
from using any kind of magic then mobius steps in
to try and speak for him and get him on his case
but when he says i thought there was no magic here
that's meant to be a callback to the first thor
movie when thor was explaining advanced asgardian
technology like the bifrost to jane foster
they made the whole joke about magic being just
advanced science that you don't understand yet
although technically there is magic and mystical
energy in the mcu but the doctor strange movie
sort of explained it using scientific principles
but one of the big easter eggs here in the
background you see the building reads t282 here
that's a reference to thor issue 282 thor vs
tempus who was a time travel minion of king of the
conkers also the tva itself is a concept debuted
in the thor comics but it's mostly been used
in thor stories and in fantastic four stories
mobius the character that owen wilson is playing
actually debuted in the fantastic four comic book
but the way they wrote him on the series is to be
sort of like the deckard character in blade runner
like you think about the blade runner reference to
all the different replicants it's meant to be the
same concept with this version of loki that we're
following as he goes around and learns about these
alternate loki's he in turn learns more about
himself and gains more self acceptance that's
sort of what that final scene with him and mobius
is at the end of the series where he talks about
not really liking hurting people i don't like
to hurt people i do this because i have to and
he sort of recalibrates his whole concept of his
glorious purpose he makes the joke about burning
the place of the ground and mobius actually makes
a reference to nightmare saying that that's a
whole other department he's making a reference to
the nightmare dimension which is the place where
the being nightmare from the comics rules make
all the one division nightmare jokes originally
he was actually supposed to be the main villain of
doctor strange 2 when scott derrickson was still
directing the new main villain of multiverse
of madness will be different though but in the
elevator you notice all the buttons go to all the
different floors it's meant to be as confusing
as possible like one of them is a miss minutes
button that probably takes you to the place where
her core operating system resides later in the
credits too in the elevator one of the readings
says access denied which would probably be part
of the big reveal about what's really going on
like big wizard of oz reference what is behind the
curtain what are we not supposed to see here when
loki calls the time keepers space lizards that's
because they kind of look reptilian in the comics
then mobius takes him into their time theater
where he shows him the highlight reel of his
greatest moment so far and his future later in the
episode although loki kind of spins that out for
himself like he just continues watching the reel
he makes a reference to loki only trusting himself
that's also foreshadowing for loki's interactions
with these other loki variants as they appear in
episodes you may have actually spotted the josta
soda reference here it might sound like a marvel
reference like joe costa but josta was actually
a pepsi energy drink it was the very first energy
drink that they tried to market in the united
states so just meant to be a reference that
because the time variance authority has ultimate
control of time travel in the timeline they can
have any kind of thing that they want we watch the
avengers take him down we watch him kill coulson
again we actually find out that loki was really
db cooper they sort of clarified the scene from
all the trailers so the way they explained this is
because loki back in the 1970s about 50 years ago
this is not an alternate timeline it's the real
main version of loki lost to bet to thor so
they're not really clear about what the bet was
about but they say basically db cooper's heist
which is a real world thing from the early
1970s is what loki had to do because he lost
the bed then he starts hitting him with the other
loki's future the original loki's future showing
him about how he was responsible for the death
of his mother frigga and that's really when it
starts to hit him and the whole reason why mobius
keeps asking him if he enjoys killing people if he
enjoys hurting people is just because he wants to
get him to the point in his arc where he's honest
with himself about who he really is and why he's
doing all these things then his woomy musaku's
hunter interrupts telling mobius they lost another
person loki uses it an opportunity to escape
but as he ducks into the desk clerk's office here
they play it for that other big reveal of the
infinity stones we find out that they are lousy
with extra infinity stones and there's obviously
a lot of other easter eggs inside this drawer that
i'll talk about in a second but just to explain
the reason why the infinity stones are useless
normally in the comics infinity stones only work
in the universe that they came from and because
the tva exists in its own little pocket dimension
it's technically an alternate reality no infinity
stones from other realities would work there
so as he says they use them as paperweights but
some of these easter eggs i couldn't quite pick
out because the text is too small a little too
blurry but like you have a poker chip here that
could be a poker chip from the first iron man
film there's a french medal of honor i'm not
sure whose historical picture this is but it feels
like it's meant to be someone incredibly famous
there's an old spanish dagger that seems like
it belonged to a conquistador there's a circular
coil of wires that seems like it's a reference to
an iron man arc reactor but then his hunter b15
chases him back down almost winds up vaporizing
him he rewinds himself back to the time theater
and uses the extra time to watch the rest of
his original timeline play out but then we
see the events of thor ragnarok he watches as his
father accepts him truly as his son like the thing
that he always wanted then he watches as thanos
kills himself and it just utterly shocked silent
by it it reminded me that scene from christmas
vacation where chevy chase is watching his home
movies in the attic just crying his eyes out and
you notice that as the timeline ends after he dies
the tape reads loki 616 a reference to the marvel
616 universe but technically in the past marvel
has used a different universe designation for
the mcu but you get the idea 616 was meant to
represent the main loki's timeline and finally
mobius comes back in after he sort of hits rock
bottom and explains what the mission is we need
you because the other person that's killing all
these men is a version of you we're hunting loki
and they transitioned to oklahoma in 1858 with
the same team from france earlier it's the same
hunter who was talking about the loki that was
stabbing people they find some technology from the
year 3000 that this alternate loki possibly lady
loki has left as a trap but they think that
someone just came to steal oil and get rich
the twist being that lady loki used the oil to
burn them down and steal their time reset device
she's going around laying traps for them stealing
their devices preventing them from closing down
these alternate timelines but then there's this
enormous montage of a bunch of different easter
eggs and references during the end credits
it's all reference to mobius case files
for instance the apocalyptic event reports are
just the standard reports about the crazy things
that happen the killings that they're going around
investigating but you also notice that the number
nine keeps showing up across the files repeatedly
like the cabinets as well so that's all probably
connected to the big reveal of this alternate
loki lady loki possibly it's being played by this
actress here who's actually with tom hiddleston at
the london premiere i'll talk more about her when
we finally actually get to see her on screen but
i'm expecting it to be kind of an agatha harkness
kind of reveal where you don't fully learn what's
really going on with her till later in the series
but everyone let me know in the comments what
was your favorite moment from the episode and
if there are any big easter eggs that you
spotted that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments i'll do
an episode 2 trailer video next and there's a
couple bonus videos that i plan i'll do a video
about the big secret wars teaser that they're
setting up in doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness connections and i'll name a giveaway
winner when i post that next video while you
wait for everything everyone click here for all
my loki videos and click here for my brand new
thor 4 love and thunder first look teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!